we are seeing a major major court case
right now before the Supreme Court that
could determine the future of marriage
and religious liberty in the United
States the case is called 303 creative
versus elenis
this is the case about a woman named
Lori Smith who is a Christian website
designer and so Lori Smith decides that
she's going to get involved in making
websites for wedding announcements you
know where this is going she is based in
Colorado you know where this is going
it's the same state that persecutes uh
Jack Phillips who's the owner of
masterpiece cake shop because he doesn't
want to participate in so-called gay
weddings well Lori Smith decides okay
I'm going to make wedding announcement
websites but I'm a Christian and so I am
not going to
participate in a so-called gay marriage
which violates my religious beliefs
the libs sue the LGBT Lobby Sues and now
this case makes it all the way up to the
Supreme Court
there was a very telling exchange
between uh justice Neil Gorsuch and the
lawyer for Colorado the solicitor
general there take a listen
I'm looking for the distinction between
the two cases one you say is okay the
other one not okay because the company
unlike our first example of the
speechwriter yeah the company here says
in no uncertain terms will they ever
sell a company as a a product or service
to a same-sex couple no what they say is
we will not sell to anyone
anyone
a message that I disagree with as a
matter of religious Faith just as a
speechwriter says for the press release
right of the freelance versus I will not
sell to anyone
speech that offends my religious beliefs
but here they are defining their service
by excluding someone based on their
that's their religious belief in
Colorado changed the religious belief
right no but but well can you protect
religious beliefs under the statue right
that is one of the protected
characteristics in theory
and in practice if it wasn't in practice
we had heard about it over over the past
several years and and my friend has
pointed to no example where this has
been applied to me the most telling part
of that exchange is when Justice courses
says look it's This Woman's religious
belief you can't change people's
religious beliefs right and Eric Olson
the lawyer for Colorado says no well
well actually that is kind of what we're
trying to do and and you see the framing
of the argument
the Colorado lawyer defending this
ridiculous LGBT law against Christians
against Jews against Muslims against
any reasonable understanding of marriage
he says This Woman's he's got kind of an
interesting voice this woman is she's
denying service to People based on their
sexual
desires she's excluding a group of
people and saying they can't buy her
product and and Neil Gorsuch says no
she's not
she's not telling any group of people
that they can't buy her product she's
just not offering a product that
violates her religious beliefs
it's not Jack Phillips the masterpiece
cake shop owner didn't say that gay
people can't buy my cakes he said I am
not going to create cakes that violate
my religious beliefs and to create a
cake for a so-called gay wedding
violates my religious belief so it's it
is it reminds me of the debate over gay
marriage which is you had the libs
saying that we want gay people to have
the same rights to marriage as everybody
else and the conservatives and the
reasonable people said everybody has the
right to marriage everybody has the
right to marriage
but marriage is the union of a man and a
woman for the good of the spouses and
the sake of the generation education of
children
everyone has the right to that
you don't have the right to radically
redefine that against what everyone ever
practically has always believed and then
the the
oral arguments got even worse from there
right now head on over to
goodranchers.com use code Knowles a hard
year on the economy means that essential
practical gifts are going to be in high
demand this year give the most essential
gift of all America's best meat and
seafood from good Ranchers with
discounts on orders of five boxes or
more you can save on gifts for the whole
family
when you give a box of good ranchers you
are giving them a true Steakhouse
experience with 100 American USDA prime
and upper Choice cuts of beef chicken
seafood other meat delivery companies
and even your local grocery stores
import lower Quality Meat from overseas
do not give your friends and family less
than America's best this year not sure
what to order good ranchers now offers
gift cards so you can let your friends
and family members choose for it
themselves or give the gift of a
subscription
and you can inflation proof someone's
meat budget go to goodranchers.com use
code Knowles kwles at checkout to get 35
off your gift that is goodranchers.com
code Knolls for 35 off good ranchers
American Meat delivered this very very
important case up at the Supreme Court
303 creative versus elenis
uh is is hinging on this issue of
whether or not you can force people to
violate their religious beliefs and
participate in
something that they find immoral and
unconscionable and so Justice Gorsuch
brings up the case of Jack Phillips and
masterpiece cake shop and having to bake
the cake and participate in the gay
wedding and he says wait a second didn't
you send that guy to a re-education camp
here's what the Colorado solicitor
general says
Mr Phillips did go through a
re-education training program pursuant
to Colorado law did he not Mr Olson
he went through a process that ensured
he was familiar he was a re-education
program right it was not a re-education
program what do you call it it was a
process to make sure he was familiar
with Colorado law someone might be
excused for calling that a re-education
I strongly disagree just discourse thank
you Mr
no it was a it wasn't a re-education
program it was a
a new instruction seminar yeah yeah
that's the ticket but it totally wasn't
a re-education program and Neil Gorsuch
says yeah okay I think I'm gonna call it
I think I'm going to call it a
re-education program I think I'm going
to stick with that
it reminds me of When Donald Trump was
arguing about the illegals and during
2016 and someone said you know that term
is very offensive
says what's offensive about the term
illegals I said what it's just it's
wrong you should say what should I say
you should say future
undocumented uh dreaming any kind of I
said I think I'm going to stick with
illegal actually and that's what Neil
Gorsuch says which is amazing from Neil
Gorsuch because Neil Gorsuch was the
deciding vote in the Bostock case which
found preposterously
that civil rights law protects sexual
orientation and gender identity that
when you see protections for sex in the
civil rights law that also implies a
protection for gender identity which is
distinct from sex by the very
nature of this gender category right the
the gender ideologues say well you can
have some sex you can be a male as as
your biological sex but you can be a
female as a matter of your gender so
Neil Gorsuch has been far from Rock
ribbed on these issues and even he is
sitting there saying are you kidding me
Colorado
are you kidding me that you're going to
force people to do this and especially
when we're talking about creating a
wedding website because there you're
talking about forcing someone to engage
in speech that they find immoral
an example of this would be I've worked
on political campaigns I've written
political speeches before
now let's say I've got Michael Knowles
speech writing LLC
and I'm a business and I write speeches
for conservatives and then one day a
communist walks in and says Michael I
want you to write a speech for me I'm
running to be the Communist nominee for
president and I say well sorry Mr
communist but I'm a conservative and so
I I'm not going to write a speech
extolling the virtues of communism
and then I get dragged before The
Supreme Court
and they say this man has discriminated
against me he has refused me Service as
a this is a horrible example of bigotry
and then the libs the lib justices say
Michael you're forced to use your speech
use your faculties of reason to
participate in this communist campaign
that's that's what we're talking about
here you are you are forced to use your
speech and your skill and your time in
your labor to violate your conscience at
a very very deep level and so Neil
Gorsuch is calling this out
unfortunately the newest Justice on the
Supreme Court katanji Jackson
did not call it out she was clearly on
the side of Colorado
what I'm asking you is I have a public
business I'm a photographer my belief is
that you know uh I'm doing It's a
Wonderful Life scenes that's what I'm
offering okay I want to do video
depictions If It's a Wonderful Life and
um I knowing that movie very well I want
to be authentic and so only white
children and families can be uh uh
customers for that particular product
everybody else can I'll give to
everybody else I'll sell them anything
they want just not the It's a Wonderful
Life depictions
um I'm expressing something right for
your purposes at that speech what about
uh what's the other step it's speech and
I can say anti-discrimination laws can't
make me sell the It's a Wonderful Life
package to uh non-white individuals
I'd like to apologize
previously on this show I have said that
I thought that katanji Jackson is a
smart woman
and I've said this because she has two
degrees from Harvard that should have
been my first warning actually and I've
said this because she was a federal
judge and I've said you know she's very
very confused this woman but I bet she's
intelligent
I I retract that statement
uh hearing
hearing that
babbling nonsense masquerading as an
argument I can no longer defend the
claim that I am confident that katanji
Jackson is an intelligent woman
thought she was but maybe not I guess I
guess my other clue should have been
when she couldn't Define the word woman
during her Senate confirmation what is
this woman saying she's saying well this
case
where a woman doesn't want to
participate in a gay wedding and quote
unquote gay wedding I shouldn't even use
the phrase because it's a it's a
contradiction in terms and this is how
the libs control your mind as they get
you they control all the words you use
and they they force you to accept their
premises as a matter of your own speech
but this woman is being forced to
participate in an activity that she
finds immoral and to do so with her own
speech
that is not the same as saying
hey hey gay people you can't buy my
pictures
hey black people you can't buy my
pictures hey I mean this this is the
silly notion
that judge Justice Gorsuch disabused the
Colorado solicitor general up when he
said you're excluding customers based on
some group characteristic they said not
at all you're just refusing to
participate in an activity
now if katanji Jackson had said you know
uh you're a photographer you want to
create real realistic depictions of the
movie It's a Wonderful Life
and you recognize that George Bailey is
a white guy so you're only going to cast
white guys in these pictures to be
Recreations of its Wonderful Life
I guess then you would be discriminating
on People based on their race but one
that's already protected it's called
casting of course you could catch you
know if I if I go in to audition for the
next Black Panther movie and they don't
give me the part I can't sue them and
say this was discrimination based on my
race how dare they not cast me an olive
skin to Sicilian American as the role of
whatever the guy I don't know what the
guy's name is I didn't it's not not my
cup of tea okay but no of course that is
is already protected and in that case of
course by the way the the person you
would be casting is not a customer he's
an employee and you were allowed to
discriminate when it comes to employees
especially if their appearance matters
so that and no one's arguing otherwise
it's just the argument either katanji
Jackson is much much less intelligent
than I thought she was or she they're
not even attempting to make a convincing
argument it could be the latter because
this was at the heart of the gay
marriage so-called debate was the libs
never had that debate
the debate was always over what is
marriage
and the libs never had that debate they
just begged the question they assumed
their own conclusion and they said
marriage is the union of any two people
that I say it is a union of and so now
that the question becomes who has the
right to get married and it seems that
katanji Jackson is doing exactly the
same thing here the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign